ich bin der Meinung dass die Politik
nicht den Mut hat den Menschen die
Wahrheit zu sagen über die Situation in
Deutschland das immer wieder nur
versucht wird mit Placebo und mit
tupferchen die Dinge zu übertünchen und
an die waren Ursachen der Probleme
unserer Gesellschaft nicht herangegangen
wird wir glauben alles mit Geld lösen zu
können das können wir aber nicht wir
können uns weiter verschulden wir können
weiter die Leistungsträger belasten was
ja der Fall ist was wir aber nicht
machen wir weisen die Bevölkerung nicht
darauf hin welche wirklichen großen
Probleme dieses Land hat die eine
grundlegenden Reform an Kopf und
hauptbedürfen ich nenne als eines
Beispiel die Überalterung unserer
Gesellschaft es sind in diesem Jahr
werden wir marschieren wir auf 114
milliardenzuschuss an die Rentenkasse es
ist dies wird bis zum Jahr
2028 auf 130 Milliarden ansteigen was
heißt denn das bei weiter rückgehenden
und jetzt gegen Schwenk Geburtenraten
das heißt Generationenvertrag ist ganz
einfach nicht mehr funktional das heißt
hier muss nachgebessert werden wir haben
eine enorm verdeckte kriminalitätsquote
im Bereich der Gewaltkriminalität das
wird schön geredet weggeschminkt in den
Statistiken die Ursachen werden nicht
klar benannt jeder weiß sie aber keiner
traut sich zu sagen ich auch nicht
mittlerweile so müssen sie sich schon
sagen ganz starke Gewaltkriminalität im
Bereich bestimmter ausländischer
mitbürgergruppen das ist einfach
Tatsache das können Sie in jedem Bild
selber nicht nachlesen in Paris zum
Beispiel da hat man in Statistik jetzt
veröffentlicht in 55% aller festen Namen
am Tag Personen die eben nicht wie soll
ich das sagen bio-franzosen sind also
sagen die flüchtlingskrise Schuld nicht
die flüchtlingskrise es gibt Flüchtlinge
und Flüchtlinge es gibt deutsche
kriminelle es gibt diesen Jesus ich
stelle aber fester sind bestimmten
Bevölkerungsgruppen auffällige
Gewaltphänomene auftreten die in anderen
Bevölkerungsgruppen nicht in dieser
Massierung auftreten ich glaube das kann
mir niemand abstreiten der in der Lage
ist auch eine betriebsstatistiken zu
lesen das ist einfach ein Fakt darüber
wird herum geredet wir sind mittlerweile
Digitalisierung in Europa auf Platz 13
abgerutscht vom Platz 9 auf platz 13 von
100 Universitäten dieser Welt besten
sind wir auf Platz 99 mit der einen
einzigen deutschen Universität München
die Politik die Verhältnisse hier im
Land wir definieren alles über eine
Erhalt des Wohlstands und das ist viel
zu kurz zu griffen ich muss Ihnen sagen
die beste Idee die ich in den letzten
Jahren gehört habe ist das Pflichtjahr
dass man einem Menschen sagt du hast
doch meine Gemeinschaft eine Pflicht zu
erbringen nicht nur zu Forderer und zu
nehmen das ist ihre persönliche
meinungstragendes und wenn das nicht
erkannt wenn das nicht erkannt ist
wieder was ich würde sagen Rentner vor
beim sozialen Pflicht ja aber gerne
genug geärgert schon ja und meine Eltern
auch ich brauche keine Belehrung
überarbeitet
in Lübeck wie sehen Sie das denn wenn
sie dazu gehören also die Politik ist
bezogen
sagen ich muss da immer sagen wenn wir
da mal einen Strich ziehen und sagen wo
hat eigentlich diese neue Ampel
übernommen und da muss man wirklich
sagen da muss ich ein recht geben die
Digitalisierung sind wir im Standard das
ist so
was machen wir so sozusagen Systeme die
sind sozusagen marode nein das mag alles
richtig sein
hat kaum mehr Munition gehabt um sich
überhaupt gegen irgendwas aufzustellen
und da muss ich sagen da ist diese Ampel
als Sie gestartet ist nicht nur mit
Krisen gestartet also wir sind ja wir
haben ja praktisch noch nicht einen Tag
ohne Krise regiert dann haben wir auch
mal so sagen und trotzdem versuchen wir
das eine zu tun nämlich Sicherheit zu
schaffen für unsere Bundeswehr für
unsere Verteidigung für unsere
Versorgungssicherheit etc pp und auf der
anderen Seite war das andere zu tun ein
neues ein neues Stadt zu sprechen ja
natürlich schaffen wir auf dem Weg also
wir sind doch wirklich auf dem Weg also
das muss man vielleicht auch mal positiv
sind und sagen wir sind auf dem Weg die
Versorgungskrise ich rede jetzt erstmal
nicht von der Preiskrise komme ich
gleich zu weil von der Person von der
Versorgungskrise die Versorgungskrise
werden wir in den Griff kriegen ich bin
mir da ganz ganz sicher ich bin ja nun
selber Vorsitzender meiner Fraktion im
im Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
und beschäftige mich damit jeden Tag und
ich glaube wirklich dass wir schaffen
werden auch durch diesen Winter zu
kommen und wir werden uns aber auch
neulich das Problem sein sondern der
nächste Wintersportler wann sie die
Zeitung lesen ne also in der einsatzung
steht so eine andere steht so also ich
glaube mit noch mehr LNG Stationen die
wir jetzt sozusagen installieren wo wir
Gas anlanden können werden natürlich die
Probleme auch kleiner werden
sie das jetzt hier hören wenn sie sich
als Bürgerin sicher ich hoffe die Zeit
ich habe dieses mäßiges Gebot deswegen
kann ich hier nicht zu teilnehmen ich
gerne möchte aber auch hier musste ich
mich wirklich zusammenreißen meiner
Themen man kann da nicht so statistisch
anmutenden Parolen
gewisse formuliert mitbringen
naja aber ich wollte schon noch darauf
sprechen kommen nein anders
die tatsächlich ist aber dass sie
durchaus recht haben was zum Beispiel
toxische Männlichkeit bei Pariser Bondy
bewohnen
Männlichkeit ich bin kein
intellektueller könnten Sie mir erklären
weil wir haben tatsächlich ich weiß
schon dann ist man gleich islamophob
wenn man sowas sagt aber sie haben
gesagt hier darf man sich äußern
Gebot erlaubt wir haben ja
beispielsweise junge Muslime die sich
dann radikalisieren in so bestimmten
Moscheen etc ich bin nicht islamophob
nur um es nochmal klar zu stellen aber
trotzdem fällt mir ein Gewaltpotenzial
auf ich lese auf französische Bücher im
Original ständig und kenne mich dann aus
die Presse verfolge ich dort auch also
das ist schon klar das sagt ja noch
macron wir haben da ein gewisses Problem
mit zum Beispiel Arbeitslosen
muslimischen Jugendlichen nicht nur in
der politikelle in Deutschland ganz
genau und da muss man halt dann auch
ansetzen mit einer ich weiß nicht wer
sich hier bei jungen Arbeit irgendjemand
macht doch auch sehr gut
Forscher also man kann da schon mit
einer vernünftigen jungen Arbeiten mal
ansetzen und dann die Leute auch
Schulen wissen Sie ich habe in Berlin
über zwei Jahre in einer Wohngegend
gewohnt in einem Haus mit über 200
Muslimen und zwar in Berlin-Neukölln
sowie vielen meiner Diskutanten oft
voraus der nun den Zucker Bezirken
wohnen und da kann ich Ihnen sagen dass
ein ganz verfestigtes hartes Männerbild
antisemitisch bis in die Knochen
auf Krieg und Gewalt eingestimmt und es
wird in Elternhäusern gestürzt in dem
Kneipen hängen Erdogan Bilder und andere
Dinge also wir was dagegen
verstreut wird die Realitäten sind
einfach anders
was würden Sie sich von der Politik
wünschen wie soll die Politik vorgehen
dass sie sich sicher in Deutschland
Straftaten begeht aus dem Status heraus
der Duldung oder ist immer wieder
verlängerten Aufenthaltsrechts muss
sofort abgeschoben werden Straftäter
sollen prinzipiell ihre Strafen im
Ausland in ihrem Herkunftsland
verbringen also zum Beispiel in Uganda
oder ruand oder so da gibt es ja
schnell wieder straffällig ineinander
eine Weile gesessen hat wir können nicht
unsere Rechtssystem auf Menschen
übertragen die kein rechtskonsens mit
unseren Werten haben das kollidiert sie
können ein Rechtssystem nur so lange
erhalten solange eine Mehrheit sich mit
seinen Grundfesten in Übereinstimmung
befindet in Frankreich beginnt 7,4
Prozent der Bevölkerung 19,8% aller
Straftaten entschuldigen Sie das ein
Missverhältnis das hat ja macron eine
Woche bekannt gegeben
Abschiebung bei Straffälligkeit bei
nichtwilligkeit hier sich an die Regeln
zu halten das ist der Weg sonst werden
sie die rechte weiter größer machen was
ich furchtbar fand wie sieht die Jugend
drauf als Jugendforscher machen sie auch
viele Umfragen wie blickt die Jugend auf
die aktuelle Lage in Deutschland
[Musik]
und vor allem stimme ich mit der
Stimmung nicht überein es ist ja wieder
so ganz typisch wir leben in einer Zeit
wo jeder ein Opfer ist und sich in
seiner Opferrolle inszeniert man darf
nichts mehr sagen man wird sofort lassen
Sie mich vielleicht auch kurz mal reden
ihren Alarmismus verbreiten
wahrscheinlich persönlich das zweite ist
ist ja ihr Alarmismus nicht meine ich
habe keine Freunde ich bin dabei ich
platzen
Emotionen die können sie sich behalten
müssen Sie selber
dieser Alarmismus und das sieht man auch
hier ja stört jedes vernünftige Gespräch
also wir können uns hier nicht mehr
vernünftig austauschen wirklich nur mehr
Emotionen im Spiegel ist Zynismus Ironie
es sind ohnehin alle Idioten und die
ganze Politik nur voll Trotteln
Politik ist an allen Schuld also man
kennt ja kennt ja diese diese diese
diese wirklich diese diese Argumentation
und ich meine ich wünsche einen Land wie
Deutschland ich lebe das seit 22 Jahren
und bin bin sehr glücklich keine ärgeren
Probleme als dass man sich gegen eine
pandemische Krankheit impfen lassen muss
und dass man im Flugzeug eine Maske
trägt also ich habe jetzt im Flugzeug
eine Maske getragen ich habe das ich
habe das überlebt nicht aber aber
es gibt auch sehr viele Menschen sie
sind nicht eingeschränkt fühlen und
nicht jedes mal so ein Gezeter aufführen
also es gibt es es gibt es gibt zum
Beispiel ich finde es sehr vernünftig
für mich im Flugzeug eine Maske zu
tragen wenn man sich dort wenn man dort
sehr eng aneinander sitzt
in Ordnung aber es ist es mich zum
Beispiel Regen andere Dinge auf zum
Beispiel regen mich Dinge auf dass man
hier zum dass man immer davon redet weil
wir leben über unsere Verhältnisse wir
müssen lernen zu verzichten wie sie das
untere Drittel der deutschen
Gesellschaft ja das lebt nicht über die
Verhältnisse sondern das hat einen Dreck
ja und die haben momentan andere
Probleme die haben Probleme ihre ihre
Miete zu und und auch auch die
Jugendlichen haben andere Probleme die
haben Probleme die die Leute haben dort
Probleme den den Kindern ihre
Schulunterlagen zu finanzieren die haben
Probleme ihre Mieten zu bezahlen ja aber
nur über den Verhältnissen leben naja
das hört man ja permanent also
schon egal mit welchen Alarm müssen ich
rede ob das einer von den Grünen ist
oder eher ein AFD nahe ist oder sonst
was ist ja es ist ja immer das gleiche
es sind es sind grobe
Verallgemeinerungen und man hat
irgendwie keinen Blick mehr für die
Differenzen in dieser Gesellschaft wir
haben wir haben die die corona-pandemie
hat das obere Drittel das wissen wir aus
unseren Daten sehr gut überstanden ja
das untere Drittel ja ist noch ärmer
geworden als es vorher war dass wir wir
mit in Deutschland
bestimmt bestens wissen was die
psychologischen Folgen für die
Jugendlichen ich weiß das ich weiß das
bestens es ist ich kann sie dann auch
kurz erklären wenn man Jugendliche und
Kinder nicht in die Schule gehen lassen
lässt dann schneidet man sie von ihrer
gleichaltrigen Gruppe ab wir sprechen
heute von der sogenannten selbst soziale
Sozialisation in der Gesellschaft die
jungen Leute unterstützen sich
gegenseitig beim Erwachsen werden wenn
ich ihnen den Zugang ja zu dieser
Gleichaltrigen Gruppe abschneide dann
produziere ich sozialisationsdefizite
mit dieser
situationsdefiziten kämpfen wir heute
wir haben Kinder die in der nicht nur
ihre psychologischen entwickeln sondern
auch in dannentwicklung ein halbes bis
ein Jahr zurück sind
da irgendwer mit sich da irgendwer nur
ein wenig so aufregen würde ja wie wegen
einer Maske im Flugzeug ja dann wäre ich
schon zufrieden dann würde ich die
Masken Aufregung auch noch gleich Abzug
akzeptieren da könnte ich Ihnen jetzt
noch ich habe die Zeit ich zehn andere
Dinge auch noch sagen worüber man sich
aufzunehmen überhaupt nicht mir geht's
einfach darum dass wir eine permanente
aufregungs eine Kultur der permanenten
Aufregung haben
über gewichtet ich möchte nur dass wir
über andere Dinge auch ähnlich engagiert
diskutieren zum Beispiel über die Armen
und in unserer Gesellschaft dass man
über die über Kinder die heute aber wie
gesagt na das ist das was ich einmal das
was diese alte Geschichte wir wird bei
uns darf keiner mehr sagen und wir sind
alle unterdrückt oder das sage ich gar
nicht mehr
wir machen jetzt einmal eine Statistik
reinschauen dann wissen Sie alle wenn
sie reinschauen